Hope like when, you know, a Seinfeld or a big act would come into town.
I was in Arizona. If you're open middle on the road, or you had a headliner,
it was all sort of like, not the same, but everyone would just.
And so whenever you're on the road, you're like, Hey,
I just worked with this guy who is your middle? Oh, it was good.
And everyone sort of knew each other over the years.
And you just realize you're all in the same racket now,
but there's like a fraternity club to that that
you just sort of with comics. I start liking them until proven otherwise.
So I'll just say, Hey man, Hey man, until someone rubs me wrong or I,
they don't like me or whatever, but overall I just get along, you know,
I will start by being cool because when I was on the way up,
people were pretty cool. And you just wanted them to, Hey, you know,
like tell me about being a headliner or ask questions about.
So it's fun.
Cause usually I want you to talk to you start bullshitting about some comic you
work with or do you know this guy? And you know some of their jokes,
you talked about the repeat, everyone, other jokes. It's fun. I like that.
So I liked the comedy world. So Adam,
he brought me into the comedy store cause I saw him. He does. He goes,
you should do sets here. I never did a set there cause I auditioned when I,
before SNL and I didn't get it, I just,
when I was 20 Mitzi and Mitzi said, now Louie Anderson got me in. Alright.
Cut the tape. What happened?
No, let me, he got me in. And he just knew Schneider's something I knew.
I knew Robin, he got me audition and she,
and he walks out on the sidewalk right there on sunset again, like so nervous.
He goes and she, and like.
Yeah, God.
And I thought he did good. Funny boys got me into the improv,
which is comedy team. And they said, they told me to start getting spots.
So I said, okay, so anyway, that's how it started.
But I never went back to the comedy store because of that.
Yeah. It's just, you know, I, Steve Harvey,
one time I saw him walk in cause he was doing like fat Tuesday, which was a.
Yeah, it was called fat Tuesday.
Yeah. Fat Tuesday. It was on Tuesday nights and it was, um, and there's,
I'm going to say this word and I don't want to get in trouble for it,
but this is what they call it. Know it was called urban comedy night. Whoa.
That's what I was called.
It was because of chocolate Sunday.
[inaudible] I didn't prep, but that's what they have. Is it the belly room?
It was no, it was in the main room. So, you know, Cedric and all these guys.
So I remember Steve Harvey came,
walked in to the building and he spit on the wall,
down the hall. I'm not kidding you down the hallway. He goes,
this club. Mitzi, shore. Try to audition for this.
So people have, you know, when Mitzi ran it, this resentment, I was at a,
I've said this before.
I was sat next to Mitzi during a showcase and this guy and
he was killing right and admitted in, she goes online.
Um, he hasn't had that and I go, um,
Mitzi that's Louis CK. He has his HBO.
Special.
He was just doing like a, just spot. No, he was showcasing. Oh. And she,
she looks at me. She goes, he hasn't had that. Oh boy, I go,
he doesn't have what? No talent. Yes. You know what I mean?
I mean, you know, no matter what you say about him, you got to say right.
It's good job.
He was so funny that night. But Mitzi is just, um.
I never met her. I never saw her my life. Yeah.
I was in the back or whatever that was pitch black dirty comedy store,
which it might get a good scrubbing while they're out.
I had Adam while you're in there,
let's get the scrubbing bubbles in there and really give it a,
but do you like the club? I do like it because I never really out of resentment.
I didn't know anyone. I didn't know how to get spots. And I just said,
I wish I had a place to practice. And then I met Adam through whatever.
And then he goes, there's your coming down? So I went down and he goes,
I'll give you a spot whenever. So I walk, he goes, just come in whenever.
So I went in, when I knew it was just go next. And then I came in a week later,
he goes, just go next. And then I go, I don't want to bump.
Then I was turning into bumping.
I go, uh.
I'll just tell you ahead and just throw me on the lineup.
And then I don't want to be one of these guys. So, uh.
Cause you were one of those people that like,
cause we had the same old before Adam, because I'd been there since 1995.
Oh really? Oh yeah. I was a doorman. I did the whole. Okay. Yeah.
So it's like, when I'd seen the same acts for 15 years,
she never invited new people in.
Right? He, he put together a good squad. My God, he brought us those lineups.
You.
Those lineups just prompt me to share like sit on it. It just starts.
To spin this way. You want a green one?
No, it was pretty.
Got to jam it so that it keeps spinning. Yeah. Whatever, you know. Yeah. Uh,
back to this. Can you hear me now?
Yeah. Yeah. What are you doing, George, please. Frank Brown.
Yet. Yeah. Those lineups are insane.